le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
Maxxo est un vrai passionné de sport il
n'hésite pas à s'engager dans les
grandes courses de montagne et a obtenu
de nombreuses récompenses
mais Maxxo ne vit pas ses passions comme
tout le monde car Maxo a perdu l'usage
de la vue à 9 ans il est aveugle à 100%.
Charlotte
un handicap majeur qui le rend dépendant
des autres et l’empêche de vivre comme
tout le monde notre société est-elle
bien adaptée aux personnes handicapées
comment maxor réussit-il à dépasser ses
difficultés à découvrir le monde qui
l'entoure à s'ouvrir aux autres on en
parle maintenant dans lien social
Maxo avait 9 ans lorsqu’une maladie le
prive définitivement de la vue à ce
moment-là il pense que sa vie est
terminée
il apprend à vivre autrement il
développe ses autres sens et un jour il
décide de se lancer dans un défi
impossible pour lui courir dans la
montagne
mais je commence courir à l'âge de 26
ans
en 86
pour Maxo la meilleure façon de
surmonter son handicap c'est de sortir
de chez lui d'aller affronter
l'extérieur même si c'est difficile et
d'aller au contact des autres
ne pas rester enfermé dépasser son
handicap par des activités et des
rencontres c'est de cette idée qu'est né
le chéquier passe loisir en 2003
en orientant ce chéquier vert des
activités de loisirs des activités
sportives ou culturelles la personne
inchiquier qu'elle va utiliser elle aura
envie de sortir de chez elle un
dispositif très simple qui donne envie
de sortir de chez soi pour pratiquer un
sport une activité culturelle ou tout
simplement se faire plaisir le
passloisier peut être même utilisé pour
aller chez le coiffeur pour nous ça peut
para
anodin par contre pour une personne
porteuse d'handicap ça peut être un
moment magnifique dans sa journée dans
sa semaine au port les Passagers du Vent
font partager leur passion de l'ULM et
sont habitués à recevoir des personnes
ayant un handicap nous pouvons
parfaitement les accueillir dans nos
machines qui sont tout à fait adaptés
pour faire des volts touristiques
labelliser Handicare on peut même dire
qu'ils se sont donnés la mission de
faire voler tout le monde sans
distinction dans leur drôle de machine
ce qui va être réalisé j'espère d'ici de
la fin de l'année c'est un équipement
des machines pour que les personnes
handicapées puissent accéder au pilotage
de ces machines et monter donc une école
de pilotage ouverte aux personnes
handicapées pour Maxo qui utilise son
pass loisir pour découvrir de nouvelles
activités voler au grand air dans un ULM
c'est une première
c'est là toute l'ambition du Pass loisir
donnez l'idée donnez l'envie d'essayer
de nouvelles activités montrer que
handicap ne signifie pas exclusion
chaque chèque du Pass loisir offre une
réduction sur une activité
Maxo utilise son pass loisir pour
s'ouvrir aux autres ils découvrent des
activités auxquelles il n'aurait pas
pensé on a fait un vol plus dirigé sur
les sensations que sur le visuel
on a fait des évolutions qui nous
permettent de ressentir l'apesanteur la
force centrifuge la montée la descente
et c'est vrai que ce public handicapé
nous amène encore plus de plaisir parce
que on fait l'effort on a besoin de
devoir vouloir communiquer ce qu'on
ressent on a pu lui faire découvrir et
ben les sensations du vol quoi tout
simplement
tout seul comme un grand
super
l'une des missions du conseil général et
d'améliorer le quotidien des personnes
handicapées et de réduire les inégalités
mais l'aide du Conseil Général en faveur
des personnes handicapées ne s'arrêtent
pas aux loisirs Le Pass transport permet
également une importante réduction sur
l'usage des transports en commun et des
taxis conventionnés par le Conseil
Général porteur du macaron passe
transport en 2011 près de 20000
personnes porteuses de handicap ont
bénéficié du Pass loisir et du passeport
deux dispositifs simples pour les aider
à aller vers des activités de loisirs de
culture de sport facilement en se
déplaçant sur toute l'île de la Réunion
le Pass loisir et le Pass transport deux
idées simples pour que le handicap d'une
personne ne soit pas synonyme
d'isolement Maxxo l'a bien compris il
sort de chez lui prends les transports
en commun
fait du sport de haut niveau
profite de la vie à chaque instant au
côté des Réunionnais
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais